you know these speeches a lot of the
speech is about thanking other people
for helping you get to where you got
this question is about you what do you
give yourself credit for in getting here
uh not giving up on myself
it's hard when you're going down this
journey you're trying to accomplish
something that you can't really see you
can see it on TV Michael Jordan Allen
Iverson Kobe Bryant but you can't see it
in your neighborhood go ahead go ahead
go ahead go ahead go ahead
yeah go ahead you got him Chris Sean
yeah you said the Marquette time yeah go
get me right
[Music]
I believed in something that my dad told
me I believed in something that my high
school coach told me my assistant coach
Gary Adams told me I believed in hard
work I believe in putting my head down
keeping my ears open and just going to
work and I had a dream and I didn't want
nothing to get in the way of my dream
not I didn't want me to get in the way
of my dream there's so many things in
life especially when you come from the
community that I come from that will get
in the way it's a lot of barriers but I
didn't want to be the one and so I made
sure I put the work in I gave myself
every opportunity to be as great as I
can be